we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah in the country of
Norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of Allah
brothers and sisters and dear friends
so this video that I'm about to do today
might be the most important video that I
have maybe ever ever done why because I
came across two videos one of Brothers
man he impregnated his own mother and
then killed her and then he buried her
in a location that nobody knows about
this person is better than the second
who used to pray in the night and
massage the feet of his mother yes if
the second individual who prays in the
night and fast in the day and he
massages defeats of his mother passes
away does having made Dua wants to the
Prophet sallallahu this person is a
hundred and ten times worse than the
first individual
and the other of another brother called
brother Muhammad on Tick Tock I felt
sick to my stomach after I watched this
video The Man Behind Me claims to be a
Muslim educator in his video he says
that if a person asks Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam to make Dua
for him
that is a hundred and ten times worse
than committing fornication with your
own mother
now the video is obviously be warned
about this individual but we're going to
be talking about which one of the two
that we're talking about and why so a
video was shared by abuteemia that he is
saying that and he gave an example and
why did you give this example in this
video we're going to dissect step by
step what is Shirk and what can lead to
Shirk and we're going to discuss that
because to me when I saw that video and
I saw the reaction
um on I'm on Twitter about some stuff on
Twitter and Etc and people messaging me
it really really made me realize the
where the ummah is at and sadly when it
comes to Shirk and tawheed it just
proved to me once again so how far we
are from understanding the severity of
[ __ ] and what tawheed really entails now
before I start the video brother sisters
I want this to be also an example
because recently as you guys know our
brother Sajid has once again attacked
another Duart and obviously deemed him
to be a misguided person and then we
always also have our brother shamsi
who's continuously attacking hijab and
finding old videos of his to attack him
today I'm going to demonstrate to the
brothers who are watching this
be it Sajid or be any of those who
ascribe to the same methodology that
when we come together against Shirk and
to promote tohit this is what it looks
like because I have personally decided
to come together by defending
ustalabotemia why not because I want
money from him not because I want him to
give me a shout out not because I want
anything from him but for the mere fact
that what he's saying is the truth and
that people are attacking and making it
it's making it seem as if if what he has
said is somehow weird and I actually
find those people weird who think what
he said was weird how let's dissect what
is brothers and sisters shirk is anybody
ascribing Partners Allah this can be
done in different ways the quraish used
to do it by worshiping the idols yes and
for example to ascribe like the
Christians who ascribe that Jesus is the
son of God yes it's a form of [ __ ] to
those who take
um the mother of Jesus peace before him
as a deity like the Catholics do those
who give the attributes and the names of
Allah to the creation and the list goes
on ship comes in different forms there's
sisters we're going to be talking about
that what is these things that are so
dangerous just so we understand the
concept of what shirk is in front of you
is going to be a video that shows our
planet our planet compared to other
planets and other galaxies the reason
I'm playing this video is so you I'm a
Layman and I'm sure most of my view is a
Layman as well they understand how
Mighty Allah is so as you're watching
this video please look at it carefully
because as I'm speaking you're going to
be seeing different planets and you're
thinking about value what's this got to
do with children you will understand
very clearly soon you will see as our
planet compared to the stars that the
Milky Way and the Galaxy you're going to
be blown away and I want you guys to
Envision that and I'm going to repeat
actually my example is probably going to
be more ludicrous not ludicrous but
Crossing all lines compared to what
osteropemia said because the reason he
gave this example was so you guys can
understand the severity and to me it
seemed like people were more outraged
they were outraged not because they
didn't understand the refutation behind
it but they were more concerned about oh
my gosh did he give an example of
somebody having dinner with his own
mother and then
um and then killing her and then burying
it somewhere people were more disgusted
with that I believe I might be wrong
then what he actually said then the
point he made I think that's a problem
so I'm going to repeat that so we
understand and I'll give you another
example imagine somebody and this is how
severe Shield case I repeat imagine
somebody who commits a zinner
intercourse with his mom with his dad
with his brother with his sister on top
of that he he decapitates all of them on
top of that he sets the body on fire on
top of that he urinated on them on top
of that he throws the body around yeah
whatever me I'm trying to make it as
crazy as possible for you guys yeah
are you disgusted of that foot I am I
feel sick to my stomach the fact that a
person who can do that to his family and
imagine his family was the best best
family to him so they did nothing wrong
not that anybody deserves this even if
they did wrong or not so now Imagine
This how bad is that now every single
one of you guys are going to be like oh
my gosh what kind of a disgusting man
what kind of a vile person what this man
deserves Hellfire forever and I would
agree with you I would agree with you
yes I would you know agree that they
should deserve Hellfire for a very long
time now put shirk into perspective
shirk is one quadrillion billion
trillion if there's any more numbers
that you can add in
worse than that
the video that you saw in front of you
of the planets and the universe and
galaxies that you're watching this is
how Mighty Allah is and how great he is
for somebody to come and say oh the one
who created all of that wow I'm gonna go
now
and thank an idol I'm gonna go now and
thank this person instead of I'm gonna
give the attribute and the Gratitude I
should give to Allah to this person now
let's come to
the people in the Muslim in the Muslim a
Muslim said who go and do this with the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
this is exactly what ustad Abu Tamia was
talking about when you go now there's
three categories this is broken into now
the first one is what that a person
believes we're not doing interfere with
anybody we're talking about a specific
individual a person believes that the
only way that Allah can hear his Dua or
accept his Dua or answer his Dua is that
he has to I repeat again he has to
ask the messenger of Allah
this is so you know I mentioned to you
guys about the person who murdered his
family is that that person is a better
person than this person
I'll repeat again yet that person is a
better person than this person why
because remember we talked about how
severe shirk is yeah just because you
cannot fundament understand it does not
mean that it's less the rights of Allah
is worse than that if you look at that
person who committed those atrocities to
his family and this you believe it is
just Hellfire you should think more of
that when it comes to Shira so a person
who thinks the only way Allah will
answer my Duan accept it is if I mention
the prophet Muhammed peace with him or I
go through him this is the highest form
of and it takes one at the fold of Islam
if they believe this yes and if they're
a one they don't know that's a whole
different story we'll contact later now
the second type the second type is an
individual around the world whoever they
may be they are sitting at their house
and they say ya rasulullah can you give
Shiva to my daughter or to my son
when they're doing that doing this what
they're what are they doing they are
giving the attribute of Allah to the
creation yes even though the prophet
sallam has passed away
they are basically saying that the
messenger of Allah can hear them at the
location they're at just like Allah can
hear them this is also Akbar the most
severest form of [ __ ] that take one at
the fold of Islam so we're not doing
masters of anyone saying if anybody
believes this yeah and this person who
does this who's calling out to the
mission of Allah yes is worse than a
person that killed like a mission his
whole family and did all that kind of
Madness this person is worse than that I
know like I said like you see the news
behind me it's a bit of truth but it's
the truth it's bitter but it's the truth
now this third type the scholars talk
about is somebody who travels to Medina
goes to the grave of the Prophet peace
be upon him and then asks him and says
all message of Allah ask Allah for a b
and c for me now the scholars differ
even Tamia said that this is better but
did he mean in the term of like it's
something that can be shirk and some of
the scholars at the ship now I wanna
rewind I want to slow down a bit Yeah I
want to make this a little bit more um
palatable for all of us
me personally to see how severe Allah
talks about shirk and how many times
Allah talks about tohid and his Oneness
and his Oneness and that when we've set
this
you alone we worship and you alone we
ask for help Noah in the Ayah did it say
you alone and the messenger of sallam
alone we ask and you alone and the
mission of we seek help and we ask we
worship and we help okay worship not we
ask for help but Ayah doesn't say that
so the point I'm trying to say is such a
severe thing that I will not go near it
with a barge pole so if Allah tells us
in the Quran
don't even come near Zina I know shirk
is worse than that maybe Zina is on the
third category after murder if I'm not
gonna even come closer dinner I should
flee the opposite direction towards the
other side of the Galaxy when it comes
to shirik this is the point now let's
talk about what is now some people have
a misconception that us wahhabis yes or
how you want to pronounce it with the V
or W you know it doesn't really matter
is that we follow
yes and look at the end of the day he
was a human being he was not infallible
there's things that he did which was
wrong but he was a man who came and at
the time when Saudi Arabian Peninsula
was indulgent again he came and cleansed
that we give credit to where Miss Jew
and he did a lot of things to
re-establish tawheed yes okay so now we
are called the vahabi and wahhabi
whatever you want to call us okay now
wasila we believe in Wasilla so some
people think this misconception We
Believe Lucille can be done in three
ways number one you can invoke Allah's
names yes you can call by his Majestic
names and say oh Allah you know I
actually did this myself I can remember
you know I was actually looking to get
married and it feels getting a little
Peak so I you know used to not that I
used to always wake her for qayam or
nothing but it was desperate times cause
for desperate measures
by Allah's names his glorious names that
Allah grant me a righteous wife
it can be done or the other way is like
we know the Hadith of the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him of the man
the three people who were in a cave and
there was a big rock that was closing it
and each of them mentioned a deed that
they did and The Rock moved a little bit
and a little bit so we know that we can
say oh Allah if I abstain from this sin
or I did this good deed for your sake
please Grant my Dua and Allah loves
those servers that ask him now go into
the example of asking somebody now
Prophet Muhammad made it made it seem
like the comments I saw he gave the Ayah
from Surah verse 64. Allah sorry Allah
says we did not send any messenger but
to be obeyed by the leave of Allah had
they after having wronged themselves
come to you and sought forgiveness from
you from Allah and had the messenger
prayed for their forgiveness they would
have certainly have found Allah most
relenting most merciful now we don't
deny that but where in that does it say
that this is talking about the present
yes it's talking about that moment if
they came and asked for forgiveness
wherein that does it say when after the
messenger has died you can go and seek
forgiveness from him where does it say
that how are you twisting this Ayah to
mean that which is very bizarre and
secondly when did we ever say that we
cannot go and ask somebody we just have
free conditions which is that they have
to be capable they have to be present
and they have to be alive
um is a fine example that he went to the
uncle of the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him and he said that we used to go
to the message of Allah when those
issues when it came to Drought or famine
or whatever it may be and we used to ask
him to make Dua now we are coming to you
so that you can make a Dua did they go
to his grave was he dead no he wasn't
did they say oh wait hold on a second
the message of Allah his grave is there
why don't we go and invoke him why don't
we go and ask him do you have a single
evidence of the companions ever in any
difficulty going to the prophet
sallallahu's grave and asking him
no you don't now if you don't what we're
seeing is then why are you angry with us
that we are trying to follow the Sunnah
where is the example that please show us
that at one moment when the companions
went through so much issues that they
went to the grave of the prophet
salallahu and said oh messenger Allah
please help us ask Allah to help us they
didn't yes so the point that was it was
wahhabis or wahhab is that you want to
go to is why go and risk your hair after
to something we're talking about shirk
we're not talking about gambling we're
not talking about murder we're not
talking about zinner we're not talking
about alcohol we're talking about shirk
that Allah says he will never forgive
why would you go down the risk and go
down that route and take a risk when you
can ask Allah directly why do I need to
invoke the prophet salallahu now some
people say oh it's because you know we
are you know we're honoring the prophet
Muhammad peace upon him we are going to
Allah directly and you guys know very
well if you guys don't know that I in
the Quran when the messenger of Allah
died many companions were distraught and
gave the Ayah which said in a nutshell
paraphrasing that those of you yes basic
messages have come before and they will
die that are you going to turn back on
your heels yes meaning that Allah is the
ever living He gave the example didn't
go to any of the companions they said by
the way you guys are very upset but
don't worry we can still go to his
Graves grave and ask him don't be upset
no he reminded the companions that Allah
is the ever living he's trying to point
out something and if you read the uh if
you really even confirm if I'm not
mistaken he says that when Abdullah
heard this he said when we heard this
Ayah it's as if it was the first time we
heard it why because Allah says remind
for remind the benefits of believer in
the moment of distress they probably
forgot and when they realized that they
thought wow subhanallah that was a
powerful reminder now for those who say
but even if I go to the message of Allah
be at Madina or where I am Etc I still
believe in Allah well guess what and
obviously I'm not talking to you guys
just so you can understand what the
shark is Iblis believed in Allah he
affirmed Allah is his Lord he even asked
Allah for respect to the day of judgment
he asked Allah for permission so Iblis
also believed in Allah now let's go a
bit you know a bit lower than ibleiz
let's go to the mushrikeen now the
mushrikeen at the time long time you
know before the whole Idol thing
happened that there used to be a
righteous person who used to serve
pilgrims yes and if I'm saying the name
was Allah something like that yeah and
they named the idol after the after him
he was a righteous servant who passed
away
he passed away when he passed away
obviously the first generation likely
that they were that was there when they
saw him passing away they remember them
as doing good things Etc and they told
their children that there was this
righteous man who used to do this and
then when they passed away you know they
got the grave and turned it into maybe a
little bit of Europe tomb there or some
kind of a you know um a a maybe not
exactly an idol but the point I'm saying
is that by generation to generation what
happened this was an evolve it evolved
and then the next Generation starts
saying oh you know this person is a you
know an awliya of Allah and the Next
Generation said this person has certain
attributes next thing you know they have
the idol of a lot yes this is what the
Muslim did so what is the difference the
mushrikeen if you go to the Quran to the
Quran Allah says the following Allah
says and listen to this very carefully
this is where you will understand
exactly that the mushrikeen fell into
disbelief even though they believed in
Allah you think that didn't believe
Allah they didn't believe in Allah all
they said is we're using these Idols to
get closer to him what does that remind
you of closer to him we want to get
closer to him we're just going through
this person to get closer to him now you
might say how are you equating a false
idol a dead Idol and either that's not
even alive to to Noble people like the
master of Allah the point is not that
Allah was once a righteous person that
they turned into the point is that you
are going through a other means do you
think if you go in front of Allah and
say oh I I went through a the message of
Allah to come across you well say well I
just went through that I do what's the
difference why is he going through why
is he going gender and I'm going
Hellfire the point is this now listen to
the Ayah they say say who is the lord of
the seven heavens and the lord of the
great Throne what would the Muslim say
would they describe it to Allah describe
it to the idols no they wouldn't they'll
say they'll say all all this belongs to
Allah say would you still not fear Allah
say who is the one in whose hand lies
the kingdom of everything and who gives
protection do you not believe that do I
not believe that guess what the music
also believed that
um and no protection can be given
against him if you have knowledge what
would they say would they say a lot no
they will say Allah say them by which
magic are you drawn crazy
the point is it's like look at what
Allah by which magic Allah saying Allah
you know this fact that Allah is the
creator of the heavens and the earth and
the sustainer and he gives you
everything yet you still go to the idols
yet you still go to them and see what
we're just going through them to get
closer to Allah we are going through
them because they were righteous and
after they've been abused when it's
given commentary of this Ayah he's
saying when you ask them they would
affirm Allah Allah Allah creates Heaven
the Earth the mountains everything yes
so brothers and sisters in a nutshell
the point that I'm seeing is that we
have ample evidence and the question is
even if we didn't why would we even get
close to Shield when Allah is talking
about over and over again imagine your
mom warns you about something and tells
you you see the house there don't go in
that house don't go near the house and
she repeats it every day every day every
day every day in out in day in day out
day in you're gonna be thinking there's
nothing my mom knows and she's trying to
protect me from I'm not gonna go to that
house but imagine somebody else comes
and goes nah nah nah nah your mom didn't
mean that you know you can't come on
guys why risk your hair after for a mere
step up that's a a slip up that can cost
you Eternal Hellfire and I'm gonna end
on this when you watch the debate
between the start after Rahman Hassan
and
um ASLA Rashid you know when that talk
was happening you caused a debate most
things went over my head one thing stuck
with me till this day you know what that
thing is
and this is when I understood
subhanallah that how dangerous some
belief systems are
when the debate ended
should we say our side the wahhabi side
was we said talkbeer Allahu Akbar guess
what the other side said
like as if we deny the message of Allah
when that was said the penny drop for me
and I said no no this is madness for a
Layman like myself just seen one prison
Allah and the other one praising the
prophet sallam compared to Allah I was
like now this is madness this is crazy
some of them have been watching them be
like look how is this disregarding the
message of Allah
really by me saying that we should
worship Allah alone we should honor him
we should seek help from him alone that
means that I'm disregarding the message
really this is how low you would go to
think that the best man to walk this
Earth the one that we try to defend his
own against his enemies unlike
individuals like Sajid and shamzi who
are looking yeah nitpicking to attack
believe that we're in the front line
trying to defend his honor yes and we
are going to be now accused of you know
we're looking for you know we're trying
to dishonor the prophet
be just you know exactly what we're
trying to say so instead of twisting
this because I know some people do this
oh look at no no one lie we're just
saying what is exclusive for Allah and
his right must be given to him but has
always seen otherwise we will fall into
exactly what the Christians fell into by
taking Jesus peace be upon him and
bringing him to a level Son of God very
righteous person Son of God too he is
Allah
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a Santa for you because
every person that comes a step closer to
Allah through your donation you and the
Lord click the link and donate what you
can